Favourite food, go. Spaghetti and meatballs. Spaghetti and meatballs, that's pretty good. What about fusilli? What about food? What about fusilli and meatballs? No, that falls under the same... That's the same category.
It's just pasta. No, I'm talking about, okay, so... I like Pat for belly. No, no, no. Let's not get into different kinds of pasta. Pasta, yeah. No, pasta. Remember when Jason...
I like French fries. If I could have one single thing, it would be French fries. One single thing. One single thing for me would be ice cream. Okay, great. Welcome to SmartLens. Smart.
Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Hey, Will, is that a... Let's go. Spider-Man...
Yeah, he's got a Spider-Man chair. He's sitting in a Spider-Man chair. It's Abel's chair because I'm in my new booth and it's not finished yet and so on. I love how you blame it on the kids. I'm not blaming it on. I'm explaining what it is. That's your new booth and your new house?
Yeah. It's not finished. I gotta put the carpet's not in yet and... Are you gonna put leather floors in this one too? You fucking douchebag. No, don't be an idiot. We're going suede. You know, I'm not happy with my podcast room set up here.
The couch I'm sitting on... None of us is. It's not comfortable. And I feel like... Can I ask you, is your couch from an old house? Is this just like a leftover? It looks like you're in a room that's full of leftovers. Like from your college days.
It is. And I'm looking at a Pilates bench, whatever you call it in front of me. Reformer. Reformer. Yeah, I just feel like it's time to admit that we're gonna be doing this for a while and I ought to untemporary my situation.
Well, make yourself comfortable. Why wouldn't you make yourself... Get something, a scenario that you're happy to go sit in. Well, also sitting up straight, Jay. Like my posture. I don't want you to hurt your lower back. Well, that's my point. It's impossible to sit up straight in this couch.
And I mean... I mean, should I dress for it too? I'm still on my pajamas. The dressing is fine. I think it's more... It's the posture I think it's... And I think it's making you... It's affecting your mood.
Quite frankly. You think I have a shitty attitude. Yeah, it's making you shitty attitude because all your organs are crunched up. You have to elongate those organs. Hey, man, let's keep it classy. So let's get on the reformer. And I'm gonna come over there.
I can be there in about four minutes. And I'm gonna come over and I'm gonna lengthen your organ. With an S or a Z. Or a Z. Okay, so our guests today. Are you guys ready for one of my great written intros again? They're so funny, guys. Now, what happens when you write...
Do you write this thing? How many gummies in there when you write this? Well, I don't think I've swallowed them yet, but I'm still sort of picking them out of my teeth. Put them in the back of your throat. So this is the ninth draft. Okay, this is how good this intro is. Wow.
Actually, it's only about six minutes old. Our guest today is one of the most popular figures in music, comma, worldwide, period. He started at the young age of 17 in the band we all know and love. Steve Winwood. Called Scream. He's now in his third band.
He's been inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and is about to be inducted for the second time. Wait, what? He's directed numerous videos and a few documentaries. He's been on SNL, Saturday Night Live, Tracy, 14 times. Wow. He has long dark hair, great smile, and loves animals, long hikes, and short stories.
He's a Capricorn, and don't I know it? Because this fella has the exact same birthday and year as yours truly, friends. This is Dave Grohl. Dave. Oh, Dave Grohl. Hey, Dave. Come on in.
Hey, Dave. Oh. Dave Grohl. Look at that Led Zeppelin book. I know. They asked for a towel to cover the camera thing. And you dry yourself off with the Led Zeppelin box set? Exactly.
Yeah. Hi, guys. Hi. Hey, Dave. Can that take us right to drumming and my personal favorite, John Bonham? Is he number one for you? Absolutely.
No question. Truly. Number one. No question. No question. No one close. OK. When I say the words Neil Pert to you, what does that do to you?
Well, he's Canadian, so it doesn't really count. He was in Rush, right? Yeah. He was the guy from Rush. Don't say he was the guy from Rush. You're being coy. He was the guy from Rush, by the way. Dave, you're being coy.
Pretty tight second. A drummer like John Bonham, you have to understand that the thing that defines a drummer is their feel, their signature sound. It's like their fingerprint, right? Every drummer has a different feel. If you have a piece of music and you give it to three different drummers, they'll play it three different ways. Personally, I think that John Bonham was the greatest drummer,
not because of his technical proficiency, which was beyond anyone else. Sure. Not because of his big fat feel, which was better than anyone else, but because he was kind of like, he like teetered on the brink of chaos the entire time. So he could like lay down a big fat groove. Cashmere, good example. Yeah, sure.
The simplicity. But I mean, listen. Frankly, when it comes to warmth, nothing beats Cashmere. But I'm sorry, Dave, I've cut you off. You were about to say that John Bonham had a heavy stick, right? He had a heavy foot. Yes, he was amazing. But here's the thing, when I was young, I got that 2112 record
when I was like about seven or eight years old, right? And I was embarrassed to show it to my friends because of Alex Lifeson's camel toe that he had in that particular kimono on the back. And I studied that record and I thought it was amazing. But it's when you listen to Rush, you kind of listen to how he's playing stuff. But with John Bonham, you're listening because you want to know why he's playing. I was going to joke and say why, but you actually said why.
It's interesting. A little side note, the boys know I just got back from Canada and on my way back yesterday, I stopped in at Harvey's for a burger. It's a great Canadian chain. Oh, right on. Oh, yeah. So I was in there, I was in there. I went in and I had to use the washroom.
Is it over here, the washroom? And as I'm in there taking a squirt all I hear is just very, very, very faintly. I just hear the backsmith and the artist must be the ones. And I'm like this. This is like the national anthem up there. I know. And I will tell you this. The first time when I was first dating my ex-wife, we went up to meet my folks.
The first morning we were in Toronto, we go to a Starbucks and we're waiting in line. Not at Tim Hortons? Not at Tim Hortons. It was a Starbucks. And in front of us was Getty Lee right in front of us. And I turned to Amy and I go every day. Every day up here is just Getty Lee everywhere. Is that right?
Yeah. Anyway. So now to close the John Bonham thing. Jason Bonham, tight second, a bronze, is he in the top five? He's, yes? Well, I do believe in the miracle of DNA. Yes. And that he inherited a lot of his father's skills.
Like when you listen, we were at a studio not too long ago, a couple of years ago. And he was down the hall recording. Yeah. And with the door closed, listening to Jason Bonham play, it sounded like a guy from Led Zeppelin play in. So you're saying the best way to hear Jason Bonham is to hear him through a closed door. I mean, that's not a resounding. He didn't say that.
Not exactly what I said. No, I know. I know. He does, when he plays with a group that plays Zeppelin, he plays exactly like John did. It sounds just like his dad. He doesn't improvise. It sounds just like his dad. This is all great for these other drummers, but I want to get to you, Dave Grohl, because
look, I have to say, you're a guitarist now and you're a lead singer and you're a frontman. But you decided to give the drums to Taylor. He gave the drums to Taylor. He wanted to let the baby have it. But I will say, I mean, Jesus Christ, it's pretty rad. Can we just take a second? Because you don't probably think about this enough. You're Dave Grohl, drummer from Nirvana.
Yeah, that's crazy. And I want to get into everything you've done since. But I want to just say that you're Dave Grohl from Nirvana. Think about that for a second. And I want you to enjoy that because that's pretty fucking rad. I bet he's never thought about it before. No, I don't think he has. But when I was in college, you get this every day of your life.
I've never met you. It's such an honor to meet you. I think you're amazing. And when I was in college, Nirvana was gigantic. And you know this, that when music has a special and penetrates your soul in a certain way that other things don't. So a lot of people have a relationship with music that brings them back to when they were in a certain point in their life.
And there's not a lot of things that do that. So for me, Nirvana was just massive, right? Thanks. It's just massive. Sorry. But I want to know because everybody knows you're such a phenomenal drummer and guitars. Is there an instrument that you've always wanted to play that
you've never picked up or learned yet? My first instrument was a trombone. And I realized that that wasn't cool. Trombone. And then I really started with guitar. That was my first instrument. But the one thing I've always wanted to do, which I promised myself I would learn someday, is tap dance.
Are you serious? I'm dead serious. Come over, I'll teach you in two seconds. Oh my God, I have the shoes, but I've just never done it. I have many pairs. I'm scared to wear them in public. I have the shoes. And one of these, I figured that I could implement a lot of
my drumming skills and my understanding of rhythm into this. I can't dance, but I think I could do it with my feet, like speed, metal, double kick drum, drumming. I'm going to need both of you to sign a release real quick. And I'm coming over too, because I'm going to video the whole thing if that would be okay. Yeah. No tapes.
And we'll both have white claws in our hands. We'll be tap dancing with white claws. Why not? Okay. So Dave, so you knew how to play the drums. You started with the guitar. But then when you did that first album for Foo Fighters, all by yourself, guys, he played every single instrument.
That I did not know. All by himself. Is that true, Dave? That whole first album is nothing but him. And it's stunning. So did that come as a result of you just kind of, you know, screwing around? Or did you go, I'm going to make an album.
I'm going to have a band. I'm going to be the only musician and I'm going to sing. And here we go. Or was it more just sort of like a, well, let's see if I can kind of do this by myself. And if it kind of gets traction, so be it. Well, when I was young, I figured out how to multi-track with two cassette players, like when I was like 10 or 11 years old,
where you can take one like Radio Shack cassette player, record guitar onto that, take that cassette and put it into the home stereo, hit play, and then put another cassette in the cassette and play drums along to the guitar. And then you'd have drums and guitar on one cassette. So I was writing songs about like fantastic quality. I just had a crazy experience when you said, when I was young, it reminds me of that lyric in your new song where you're like,
when I was a young boy, when I used to have a toy gun. What is that song? It's called Waiting on a War. Waiting on a War, which I've listened to a lot. Cause I listened to a lot of UK radio, you guys. Oh. Cause yeah, cause I'm kind of cool. And my buddy, Johnny Vaughn, plays it a lot on his radio
station over there. He's a great guy, very hilarious guy. Much funnier than these two, Dave. And he plays it a lot and I love that song. It's such a, yeah. Have you guys heard it? No, they haven't. But it's such a great song.
I'm sure they have. It's such a great song. Dave, can I ask you a question? Hang on. Host of the Year has a question. Go ahead. Here we go. Everybody's favorite host.
Go ahead. Wait, what's going on? Sean's everybody's favorite. It's so stupid. We just got, we just got some eye heart. He definitely talks the least. Dave, Dave, we just got some eye heart. How do you do it, Sean?
Hold on. I'm talking to Sean. Sean, Sean, you and I, come on. I wait, I wait for a sliver of an opening and I jump in there. I'm sorry. No. How do you like your omelettes? I don't know.
Yeah, there it is. Go ahead, Sean. Because I've never met you. I'm truly a big fan. I have to ask you and I apologize because you probably get this a lot. But when you were in Nirvana, I know, hold for it. He loves talking about Nirvana. I just loved them.
I loved you and I loved them so much. When you were in it and you were first like meeting and creating music and recording together, did you all know you had something special where there was their in fighting? You're like, this is never going to fucking work out. Like, what were the dynamics? Well, I joined, I met them through a mutual friend. We was in a band called Scream and we came out on, we toured in a van and we toured America, played little clubs and blah, blah, blah.
And we wound up on the West Coast. Our bass player Skeeter decided to just go home without telling anyone. And we were stuck here. That sounds odd for a guy like Skeeter to just disappear. I know, imagine. And it wasn't the first fucking time he'd done it, by the way. He did it in Europe anyway. You think he got his name?
Yeah. So we were stuck in a house in Laurel Canyon full of mud wrestlers who worked at the Hollywood Tropicana. Where in Laurel Canyon was it? It's right next to that house where Ruben records stuff that like mansion. Yes. I know exactly what it is. It's directly next door to that.
And so our guitar player and singer were brothers and their sister worked at the Hollywood Tropicana. So we had a place to crash. Anyway, so the Skeeter goes home and then this friend of mine says, hey, you know, Nirvana is looking for a drummer. And I'd heard their first record and I loved it. I thought it was great. And he gave me their number and I called them up and they said, actually, we already have
a drummer. I was like, cool, okay. Well, if you come down to LA, I'm just living in a house full of mud wrestlers. And so then they called back that night and said, maybe you should call Kurt. And then I got on the phone with Kurt, we started talking and he said, all right, well, if you can come up to Seattle, let's jam. And so I flew up there and yeah, within like two minutes of us playing together, it sounded great.
Really good. No, no, no. Go ahead. Well, just to that, like kind of like to Sean's thing, like when you're in that gym recording the video that everybody's seen a million times and you're going nuts. It smells like Teen Spirit. Yeah. I don't even need to say it.
It smells like Teen Spirit. One of the most iconic songs. Did you know in that moment, you're like, we're doing some pretty fucking rad and different here. No, we were like, this is the most spinal tap moment of our entire career. Are you serious? Yeah. I mean, because it was like, there was like fire machines.
And I directed with a bullhorn like, more fire, more fire. It was like, it was kind of a little weird. When they said, okay, you should call Kurt, was that because you needed to just kind of do like a personality test with him or did you guys talk drum theory? Was it like an audition type of phone call? Well, they had seen our band scream play and I was the guy with the big drums that would beat the shit out of the drums. And they basically said, like, well, if we could get a guy like that, I'm like a disco
drummer. It was very ACDC full on just like, that's what they needed. And so, and then I just happened to be available. And so when we went up and started playing, also I sang backup vocals, which Kurt was putting on some songs. And so I could sing that too. Was there any joy from Kurt? Like, because every interview, every story, everything I've ever seen is just very heavy
and dramatic. No, this is a popular misconception about Nirvana that it was a total drag. And it wasn't. Yeah, you seemed pretty funny. Kurt was really funny. It had a really fucked up sense of humor. That was great. It was really, really funny.
And Novoselic too, the bass player. I mean, we were like the Adams family. Novoselic is six, seven and a half. Right, right. The unplugged MTV, you could tell you guys had a great sort of fun kind of chemistry. You could tell things were pretty dry and rye. Always. Yeah.
But I mean, but then there were times that were really difficult because we basically went from sleeping in a squalid little apartment, eating corn dogs every day to becoming this thing that people now know as Nirvana in the course of like four weeks or six weeks. Right. We were kids. We were like 22, 23 years old. Right. So it was really, there were times that got really difficult.
Was that like the middle of 91 when that just first exploded with that? So it was September of 91. Yeah. So that was the first thing that you bought that you felt like, you know what? This is really irresponsible of me. The first thing I did, the first check I got was 400 bucks. It was the most money I'd ever had in my entire life. From Nirvana stuff?
Yeah, 400 bucks. I was like, fuck. And I went to the Fred Meyer, like Kmart store. I bought a BB gun, a Nintendo, and I got a fucking tattoo. And then I was back to the corn dogs. Like I had nothing. So I fully MC hammered it within like 24 hours, just fucking dropped the whole thing back to the couch in the corn dogs.
It's good to learn that lesson on the 400 bucks. So when the big check comes, you go like, all right, I'm not going to do the BB gun again. This is one of the beautiful things about some rock stars. Like you think about someone like Steven Tyler. Oh my God, that guy's had $10 million and then $10 million and then $10 million and then $10 million. And I don't know if he's buying BB guns and fucking Nintendo's, but it kind of goes
like this. But actually when we started making real money, my father, both of my parents were musicians. My dad was a classically trained floutist and my mother sang in acapella groups and stuff. So we love music. Anyway, my dad was also, he was a conservative Republican speech writer on Capitol Hill and at a journalist and a campaign manager. And my mom was a public school teacher, like liberal, cool.
They were very cool. But anyway, so when we first started making money, my dad was like, you know, this isn't going to last, right? And I was like, no, of course. He said, you have to treat every check you make like it's the last one you're ever going to make. He's scared the fucking shit out of me. And I still do this.
Like I still, everyone I get, I'm like, well, that's it. I guess I'm fucking out. Back to shake his pizza. I'm fucking. Yeah, right, right. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. You like me did not finish high school.
And that has been one of the things that's sort of driven me to constantly try to stay a few years ahead to make sure I don't run out of employment or, you know, cash or anything. Is there still some part of you that still sort of like, got to stay ahead, got to got to keep this thing going. They're going to kick me out any minute. Always. Yeah.
I mean, when you like, so my mother raised my sister and I on like the public school teacher salary. Yeah. So it's like month to month. You know what I mean? So I sort of realized at an early age that she was working at the school and Bloomingdales and serve pro carpet cleaning. I'm like, oh shit, you have to work your ass off to stay ahead of it to have food.
You know, and so Virginia where you grew up. Yeah. Just outside of DC. Yeah. Let me ask you this. What were the bands that you were like, right when you were getting to, I know you talked about Zeppelin and I know we all appreciate, I love those bands and I have an eclectic like people say, I'm like, I'm not a deadhead, but I've seen the dead like 11 times.
Like, but I'm not a deadhead. I think that makes you a deadhead. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. I'm pretty sure. I once saw in the same. Were you like spinning and taping and doing a fish fan? No, no, no, no.
Do you have a tie dye in the closet? Don't fuck your life. I was selling devil sticks out of the back. I actually have you ever worn tie dye short? I mean socks. That's a big one. No, never. But I do.
In sandals. I have a brand new all black, the Grateful Dead. They do send me. It's a weird story. They, the band sends me stuff sometimes. Anyway, I will say this. I saw within a week, I saw Bob Dylan's and in the Jerry Garcia band, both sing forever young within seven days of each other.
Anyway, but my point was this. What kind of music were you? I know I was trying to get into like we're all into a collect. You love Zeppelin. You love, but was there one kind of music that you loved more than any other? Like were you an indie guy? Were you a pop guy? Metal guy.
I was first, I was a Beatles guy. And then I got that rush record with the camel toe and I was afraid to let anyone hear it or know that I was listening to, I hit it like I under my bed. Like it was a playboy. I hit it under the bed. And then, and then I discovered punk rock music. I went up to Chicago. I have these cousins that live in Evanston outside of Chicago.
And we would go up every year from Virginia for. Yeah. Well, I'm from Chicago. I know I was. Oh, there you go. So my cousin Tracy lived in Evanston right off the lake on this. You have a Tracy? I do.
Wait a minute. You have a cousin named Tracy in Evanston? I did. Oh, no. She's not dead. She's just in Florida now. But anyway, so anyway, so I went up there and she had turned into a punk rocker. Like we got one summer we show up and she's got like chains and boots and the jacket and
the shave head. I was like, I'd only seen that on like Quincy and chips. I'm like, holy fucking shit. This is real. Oh my God. Wait a minute. Yes. The problem child that needs to be rescued.
That night she took me to the first time I ever saw a band was this punk rock band from Chicago called Naked Reagan. Yes, of course. Right. They were playing at the Cubby Bear right across the street from Wrigley Field. Yes, of course. So she took, I was like 13. She took me to the Cubby Bear and I'm like, all I knew about rock and roll was like the
lasers and the dragons and the castles and the fucking kiss and shit like that. So this was like this tiny shitty little room with the tiny shitty little stage and they had two tiny shitty little lamps and there was a microphone and they started playing and the place fucking exploded and like spit and blood and puke and fucking guys standing on my head and I was like, oh, this is rock and roll. That's pretty wild. So then I fucking dove head first into that whole punk rock thing. But the thing that I loved about it is that all of these bands were totally doing it themselves.
Like there was no record companies. They had their own record companies and made their own. So you're like Fugazi, like that whole vibe? Like Fugazi. Yeah, like Fugazi. Yeah. That whole scene. Well, that's where I grew up in DC.
Right. Like those were our friends. The 930 Club? Yeah, the 930 Club. Yeah. So how much time did you spend in Chicago? We'd usually go for like a couple of weeks and then we'd go back home. Yeah.
Do you ever go to Medusa's? I did not go to Medusa's. If it's like an ice cream shop or something. What is it? Yeah. So is that where you used to go? Pants Tailor? No.
So speaking of pants, speaking of the camel toe and everything, once you got off the drum stool and you became lead man, you're up front, was there a pressure to work on the inseam at all? Like when you're up front, do you have to, what is the rock and roll sort of rule there that you, can you wear baggy pants as a... Wait, huh? Yeah. We're talking about...
Can you wear baggy pants as a singer? Yeah. Or do you... Do we have to talk about MC Hammer? This whole podcast? Is that what we're doing? MC Hammer and John Bottom. Go.
Well, I mean, I didn't put that much thought into it. One of the reasons why, okay, so I go and I record that thing by myself. Where? The first record. It was just the first Foo Fighters, it was in Seattle. There was a studio right down the street from my house and I'm like, okay, I need to do something. Right.
Because I stopped playing music. I didn't want to become someone else's drummer and I was, you know, our whole world was turned upside down. And you went to Ireland and there's this great story about a hitchhiker there, if you want to share? Yeah. So after Kurt died, everyone just kind of retreated into our corners and we kind of hid from the world.
And I decided to go on this like soul searching, find the most remote place on earth trip. And I went to the Ring of Kerry in Scotland where I'd been before and I decided I was just going to drive around and think for a while. And I was driving down this country road and I saw a hitchhiker and I thought, well, maybe I'll pick him up. And as I got closer, I saw that he had a Kurt Cobain t-shirt on in the middle of nowhere. And it was in that moment that I'm like, okay, I can't outrun this thing. I need to like, I need to play music.
That's wild. And so then I went back and booked six days in this little studio and just recorded the 15 songs by myself thinking, okay, I'm just going to make a cassette and hand it to some friends and what it was not like a career decision. It was like, okay, I'm just going to do this because I felt like I needed to do it. But it made you go, good. I thought you were going to say, so I strangled the guy and I hit him in some bushes. Okay, good.
You did not do that. That did not happen. Okay, good, good. Fuck no. Fuck out of there as fast as I could. Man, that album is so great as all the ones that followed have been as well. But that was kind of your like, you realized that like you had to kind of, I love that idea, like that headspace that you're in that you're like, you're like, okay, universe,
I hear you, motherfucker, I'll go, I'll do it. I'll jump back in. Just steer right into it. Well, I mean, if you think about it, like your entire life, listen, in the darkest moments of your life, you've probably turned to music and listened to music to help heal whatever you feel. 100%. So I kind of went in that, at first I'd stopped listening to music and then I'm like, no,
wait, it's kind of healed me my whole life. Now I need to like get back into it. Right. 100%. I get that. Was it transitioning off of the drum set and going upfront and finding Taylor and kind of handing that off? It's a drum kit, by the way.
It's a drum kit. Sorry. Yeah. So the whole thing, did you want to sing and play guitar and be upfront or was it, what was that decision process? No, it was totally weird and foreign and I hated it, but that's kind of why I did it because I didn't want to just go sit and play the drums some more because I kind of knew I could do that, but this was something I didn't know that I could do.
And you had some things you wanted to say, yeah, with writing lyrics and... My lyrics are fucking terrible. I said absolutely nothing at all for the first 10 years. Maybe the last record, I actually said something meaningful. Are you conscious of that when you're writing, I'm not agreeing with you, but when you're writing lyrics, you're like, I'm not even going to try to do anything somewhat profound. I remember spending so much time on the lyric once and our bass player Nate said, dude, not every song has to be imagined.
You know that, right? And so then I was like, really? Yeah. I was like a fucking bullshit. Right. Wow. Can we go back? So who was the floutest, your dad or your mom?
Dad. My dad. Did they encourage you to study music and to learn music theory and things like that? Or are you just by ear? I just kind of went by ear. There was this old guitar in the corner of our house and I felt like around nine years old, I picked it up and I was one string, I'm like, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. I'm like, oh shit, this is easy.
Yeah. And then I just fucking... Wow. And then I had lessons and I had this Beatles songbook and we play a lot of Beatles stuff. But drums, I would set up pillows in my bedroom on the floor and learn how to then put on records and do it that way. Does any part of you want to go learn, not that you have to because you're brilliant, but go back and kind of learn all of the, how to read music and how, and the music theory
of it and chord progressions and time signatures and all that kind of stuff? Oh god, that sounds like a lot of fun. Yeah. No. There is no part of me that wants to do... Yeah, now that you've got a lot of money and time to do whatever you want, do you want to go into the recent boring shit? Fuck that.
You know, I actually had a plan when I was young. I was like, okay, since I'll never become a professional musician, I should learn how to read music and I'll become a studio drummer and then I'll make enough money that I could put myself back through school and then get a real job. Yeah, right. Right. And then I was like, fuck that. Can I ask a dumb question?
Can you read drum music? Do drums have notes? Yeah, they do and they look like squiggly little lines. I don't get it. They're X's, where the notes are. They're just X's. Okay, Sean, like let's learn how to play some drums right now. Sean, very studied.
Sean, that's what he's talking about with this. Maybe you can teach me to play the drums as well. Tap dancing, drumming. Yeah, if you got some extra time. Dave, he's trying to get you to, he's trying to identify, he's working towards, ask him Sean about musicals. Fucking ask him. No, no.
Just do it. I do have another question though about genres of music because there are certain genres of music. Have you seen promises, promises? Have you, is there a certain genre of music that you aren't drawn to? Like, you know, there's so many. There's country, there's pop, there's rock, there's rap, there's just tons and tons. Is there something that you're like, eh, that's not for me?
I'm not the biggest country fan. I have to be honest. Good for you. There's certain things that I kind of like and there's certain artists that I respect and think are really great. Maybe you and I can get together and watch a Ken Burns documentary on country and get to know it and get to know it. Should we do that?
Yeah. Should we go? I mean, I went to, like I did this HBO series called Sonic Highways and I went to Nashville and did a whole episode on Nashville and it was really interesting and of course, like, Nashville's, that's the town with the best musicians. That's the place where you walk down the street, look in someone's window and they're playing like a dulcimer or something like that. That place is filled with the most brilliant musicians.
I don't know why. It's just, I've just never clicked with the country. Tell me how you like or not like the being sort of the frontman, the leader, the dad in the band. The dad. Well, but I mean, you know, I put it together and he's the boss and how do you like managing the inevitable ups and downs of traveling and living together and probably spending more time with one another than your actual family?
Hang on. Before you answer, sorry, Jason, I just want to get you up and just say, or the mom, just because, just to cut off all, you know, to head off the letters we're going to get. He needs to be mom too. You know, there's mom. It's such a dummy. Wow. Will's policing this whole thing.
Yeah. That's a bad sign. That's not cool. Yeah. That's like me being the front person of a band. Bad. Bad idea. But are you good at smoothing out conflict and doing all the administrative stuff that
one needs to do in a band or not? Well, we've been a band for 26 years, which is amazing. It's 26 years. That's great. It's just that eventually you come up with some sort of system that works. And I always liken it to like wheels and a clock. There's like the big wheel that rolls slow. There's a little wheel that kind of does this.
And when the gears meet, like that keeps ticking. And so, you know, I like to be in a band, right? Right. Like I like it when everybody is there for the same reason and everyone's contributing and it's really awesome. Do I have to make like sort of weird decisions, tough decisions sometimes? Yes. But I refer to different members for certain things.
Like if I have a sort of like a, any sort of like ethical dilemma or crisis, I turn to Nate and Pat and I'm like, what should we do? They're like the barometer. If it's, if we need to have like a stadium rock ending to a song, I turn to Taylor and I'm like, Taylor, what would Queen do? You know, so. What about T-shirt designs? Who's got, who's got?
Never me. T-shirt. Absolutely not. Never, never, never me. Really? No. Who's got the taste on the graphic art? It's probably like Nate and Chris.
And you know what, to be honest, I don't fucking care. So I just kind of back out and go like, yeah, whatever you guys want to do, I don't fucking care. You don't care for real? When it comes to album covers and shit, yes. We haven't done a coffee cup for a while or what about a good key fob? You're not, you're not. Yeah, that's an email that I swipe and delete.
By the way, those are Bateman's best ideas, coffee cup and a fucking key fob. God, I designed the greatest key fob. Look at the, he's aesthetically inclined, he's just taking a look. This looks like just a generic hoodie. It's $6,000. By the way, we should mention, this is a great time to mention because we've never mentioned it except for when we do have a hoodie, we have a website, I just thought about that this week.
We have a website. Oh, you have merch. And we have merch. We've never talked about it. Cool. Go to foodfighters.com. Foodfighters.com. Yeah, it's weird that we're selling ourselves at foodfighters.com.
Dave, when you were growing up, it's clear that you kind of, you know, took influence from your dad and the music side and a lot of kids either go one way or the other, right? You go, oh, I want to do what my parents do or I don't, I want to run from what my parents did. Is what about your kids? Is anybody kind of... In your case, your parents just run. Right.
Sorry. Not your dad, but keep going, Sean, sorry. And I stayed put and got fat, but anyway, but is what about your kids? They want to do it, dad? Does they run or run? Well, my daughter Violet, who's 15, she is the most talented musician that this family has ever known. Oh, that's cool.
Like she has perfect pitch and she has like an incredible memory, musical memory. She could pick up an instrument and learn it in like a week. She's a total badass. Does she think you're a badass or does she think, oh, he's dad, he sucks. He's a dad-ass. No, I think she, you know, she's grown up like, you know, I've been carrying her backstage since she was, you know, so she's seen this whole thing like from the ground up. She gets that you're good, that you're not just screwing around.
Well, she gets that I work really hard at trying to make good records and stuff like that. And that's a big part of it. How does she handle all the travel? I mean, she doesn't know any different, hopefully, like my kids, like they just kind of deal with it and I don't see any problems yet, but how does the family deal with you being gone all the time? Well, you know, she's actually, she's one of our backup singers now.
Oh, great. So she comes on the road and we like, we share a room. She's like on that side of the suite. How old is she? I'm on this 15 and a half. On this side of the suite, wake up in the morning and I like order room service and I'm like, it's time to get up and then we like have some breakfast and then we roll our bags down to the thing, then we go to the thing, 100,000 people, then we go, we get a pizza
and then we watch a horror movie and it's actually really awesome. And then my daughter Harper, she came up to me when she was like nine or something like that. And she said, I want to learn how to play the drums and I'm like, drums, like that's some fucking mail room positioned shit. Really? Like straight to the drums, usually you get demoted. And so I was like, okay, so I started showing her how to play the drums and she has like
an internal meter where she's got really good time and she understands how that shit works. And I sat her down and gave her an AC DC record and she was like, she has feel like she's really got it. She did it for like three months and was just like, fuck that. By the way, that was really good already. Did you show her the videos of Nandi Bushall? Oh yeah. Well, you know what?
They're actually my daughters. I wrote a song for Nandi and my three daughters were the backup singers for the song that I wrote for Nandi. Oh, that was that girl, that English girl that you got into the thing with? Yes. That was so real. That was so, so real. I have a question about what you just did, because that was kind of mind blowing, what
you just like, Will just said, that was crazy. The thing about drummers is that is like this internal thing, how do you learn how to, I mean, it's you keeping the rhythm for the whole song, for the whole show all the time, every song. And how do you learn how to do that? You know, I'll tell you, when I was a kid, like when we would, my grandparents lived in Ohio and we would drive from Springfield up to Youngstown, Ohio. And when you pass through Pennsylvania, you're going through all of those tunnels through
the mountains and stuff. So you have a radio station on and there's a song is like, and then you go into the tunnel and it's gone and you try to keep time with it. So when you come out, it's like, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle. So I would do this game in the fucking tunnels to see if I could actually keep the meter going like that. And so I did that my whole entire life. But all joking aside, and the tap dancing, I never joke about that.
That's no joke. You have to be. You have to be a good dancer because not that you've tried maybe or I don't know, because it's your whole body is rhythm. Yeah. But that's kind of the last thing you want to see from anyone on a dance floor because I'm either going to like do the fucking robot or it looks like a dead head like will or it's like it's not.
I don't know. But how is that? How is that? How is the rhythm, the internal rhythm, the clock that you have? How is it, you know, shown up in other parts of life? You know, I could play drums with my teeth. You can. What does that look like?
Let me see if I can. I can do this with my with my mouth and my nose by breath. I can go. Oh, I heard that. That was cool. I was like, check it. Yeah. It was a little bossa nova.
Yeah. Wait, do you do blow? Do I do blow? No, I don't. She's still, yeah. Hey, he really should dry it though. Yeah. It's real fun.
Sorry. That's just an aside. So, hey, Sean, Sean, did you do that because you wanted to try to figure out how to smell your own breath? Do any of you guys know how to smell your own breath? I'm sorry, what's the question, idiot? Sorry, I just want to double back on the camel toe question for Dave
and then when I want to get to breath smelling, I'm kidding. Guys, I'm the best host of the year. What about these questions? What about these questions? I had a joke that I was gonna make that even I wouldn't make, so I didn't make it. Do it, we can cut it, go.
No, I'm not gonna do it. Really? No, I actually have a line. All right. Okay, Dave, what about directing? Do you have a passion for that? Or is it just like, ah, fuck it, I'm tired of listening to these guys direct our videos.
I'll tell where to point the camera and stuff like that. Or do you have a passion for that? Well, most of the videos that we've done, like I have come from crazy dreams that I've had. And so, and we would look through all the treatments, people would send us and I'd be like, man, what doesn't really, man, and then I would write a treatment
and someone would say, do you want to direct it? And I'd say, I have no idea how to do that. And then I would do it. And so I've done it a bunch of times. And then the documentary stuff, like that stuff just kind of fell into my lap. And that's really fun. I really enjoy doing that.
Who are the musicians now? And all jokes aside from going like, you know, like Elvis Presley, like who are the people you would like to, who are still making music or have been making music in the last 25 years, current recording artists that you're like, or that you would like to make a record with or you think is fucking cool or doing something that's cool.
And I don't mean like, I want to do with Justin Bieber, like forget the mainstream. And I don't want to hear the ironic answer. Tell me the real answer, not like the thing that you think will, you know what I mean? Yeah. I know I've met a lot of really amazing musicians. I'm sure everybody, you've met everybody,
like Steve Malchemist, like somebody like that. Like he's one of the most- Well, I'm more like Omar Hakeem and Nile Roger and Greg Kirsten and like just like assemble like a real like bad ass group of people to go in the studio for one week and then just like bang some stuff out and see what happens. That's really fun. Cause when you meet musicians
that you've never really played with before, you meet someone and you try to carry conversation and you try to like make friends this way. But when you put on instruments as musicians, like those conversations can be more fun and deeper. When there's no language, you're just like playing the music together. That's really awesome.
Cause then you almost, you find out what type of person they are by the way that they play their instruments. So that's why I love jamming with so many different people is that it's like, you know, once you sit down and start doing it, you're like, oh, that's who you are. Oh, okay, cool.
I tried to make a conversation with Dave once during some of my, my, my, before I lost my privileges. This one I was really thirsty during my peak drinking. Sure. I was over at, I think it was Trader Vicks in Beverly Hills. Oh my God.
You know- How psyched was he when you- Yeah, well, hold on. Yeah, he let me know. I was deep into my third scorpion bowl and there's Dave Grohl sitting in a booth. And I had just learned that we share the same birthday and year.
And I just thought he would be thrilled to learn this too. I am, I have been. No, no, but- Remember the time we had the birthday show at the forum? I was so excited for us to share an arena concert. But this was- Celebrating our birthdays. But this was my first, this is my, my, my passion for you
was running white, hot. I'd never met you before and there he is. And I just learned we share the same birthday. So what, that's no wonder why I think this guy's so amazing. So I slide into the booth next to him and I just give him the eyebrows and I say, hey, guess who's got the same birthday as me? Same year.
Just smiling at him, waiting for a like a fucking what? And he looked at me. I did, this is all, did my, my drunk memory. I'm sure he was very, very nice, but I just remembered just whatever the physical facial equivalent of crickets is, I got it. Now that's pretty spot on. That's pretty spot on what you're describing.
It was, right? Yeah, pretty much. I can't see Jason's face. So fucking what, Jason Bateman? I'm here, right? How crazy is this? We'll be right back. All right, back to the show.
Are you always someone who kind of, cause you are, you seem, if so much energy, you're super funny, you're always writing, you're always making, creating something. Are you that kind of personality? It just goes, goes, goes all the time. And if so, how do you relax? How do you calm down?
What calms your brain down? Or no, you're just- White claw. White claw. No, yes, I'm a total spaz. That's the short answer. What do I do to relax? Is there anything that calms you down?
I don't know. I don't have any hobbies. I don't know. What, or do you go to the, like, no, you don't work out? Let's, come work out with me, Dave. Come over to the house. No. Yeah, no.
Dave, are you, are you a spaz all day? Or are you like me? Yes. Cause we are the same age. Do you crash? Yeah, at like four o'clock. Is it a testosterone thing? Is it a-
You might want to get your thyroid checked. Are you napping at all now, dad? I'm a bad napper. No, not a good napper. No, not good. No, I pretty much spaz all day. I, you know, it kind of ramps up around, what time is it?
10, 11 o'clock in the morning. Yeah. Peak. And then it peaks spaz and then it kind of dips a little bit. Let me ask you guys, like a- And then the white claw. A really dark week stream is a good sign, right?
Yes, especially if it smells like maple syrup. I think that's what you're referring to, right? Just checking. I'm healthy. Dave, dark and weak. I love it. Dark week stream. Dave, but we do, I do want to know though, like,
is it like, are you a bass, do you watch baseball? Or do you anything like that? No, I don't watch sports. No. Okay, you don't watch sports? No. The closest thing I had to sports was, I was on a skeet shooting league for a while.
That's pretty- It's pretty fun. That's like- That's pretty dope as hell. That's my sport. With Skeeter. Like, Skeeter. How often are you playing music?
Is it every day in some capacity? You're picking up and just kind of like, noodling around on the guitar, looking for a rhythm that might become a song? That happens kind of every day. But- What do you listen to in the car? Do you have a radio? Do you listen to radio at all, ever?
I do. I listen to old school. First of all, like, just the fact that I'm on a computer right now with the thing that's connected to this other thing, all this, is a fucking miracle. I'm the most, like, Not tech chef. AM radio analog dude.
I drive around in the car. I listen to KLOS or whatever. You do? And I hear like Fog Hat again. And I still like it. And yeah. Or, you know, I'm also a YouTuber. So I'll wind up watching videos of songs.
Like I just, the other day, remember that they might be giant song. Put a little birdhouse in your soul. Yes, it's one of my favorite groups. Well, I hadn't listened to them in like 30 years. And in the last 12 hours, I've listened to that song like 1200 times. It's the best.
I love all of it. It's amazing. Like I'm even watching like covers that people have done of, you know, whatever. Yeah. What about this sort of this move away from, it's happening over the last 10 years, probably 15 years, away from real drums,
real guitar, real everything. And it's becoming much more sort of electronic. And you can kind of make a whole album on a computer. Really last 10 years. Have you ever heard Soft Cell? Yeah. Come on, man. No, but I mean, you know what I mean?
What is it, 2011 right now? What are you talking about? What? But like, there's no more like amps. And there are like, remember the last time, I mean, there are moments where you see it sort of poking its head into mainstream music. First of all, it's not like a meteor crash
dinosaur extinction level event. It's like guitars and drums. Thanks to you guys and a couple of other bands, you guys are keeping that thing going strong. But you know, like the day is like, the new band used to be, you know, like white stripes or something that's just like hardcore. But now it's like anything that's like, yeah,
but like super techno, electronic, odd, you try to find a rhythm and you can't is sort of the new, some of the new sort of. I mean, it's also very cyclical. Well, something will be really, really popular for a while. And then that becomes like, oh wow, they're using guitars and drums. Like if you look at, I mean, first of all,
Miley Cyrus is like becoming the next Joan Jett as we speak, like this is really happening. Yeah. I mean, she goes out and she's like a rock star, you know? Or like when Lady Gaga played on the Grammys a few years ago, like instead of doing her huge production, she was like, it was almost like she was Ziggy Stardust. She was like singing with the band behind her.
Hey, Dave, let me ask you, what's your favorite beat of all time that always gets you? There's like, there's a song that comes on, you go like, fuck, I just love that. You know what it is? It's that reggaeton beat that's like. Is there a song that has, what is that? There's 10,000 songs to do that.
Like that, right. Like Justin's got one and Selena's got one. I was just thinking like, I love that. You remember that like Stone Roses, Fools, Gold? Love. Love. Yeah, it's a Manhattan beat. Well, you know, this is the thing sometimes.
Dave, did I get that right? I don't fucking know what any of you guys are talking about. When there's sometimes, when a beat will define a whole genre of music. And this is dangerous, I think, because then all of a sudden your band or your type of music you're playing is restricted to this one thing.
And it happens something, like trap music. When all of a sudden, when it was like, and you're going like, hit it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, that was like three years ago or whatever. It's gone, right?
It's gone. Exactly what you mean. Because it was the same fucking beat in every fucking song. Well, Will, I know what you're talking about. That song, that Stone Rose song, everybody emulated that beat for like seven years. Right after that, that was like 1989. And it was just like, boom.
All those bands out of Manchester specifically, but it was like so good. And God, I love that band. Dave, true that you broke your leg, went backstage, got a cast on it, came back out, finished the concert, then had a throne built to continue the tour. Is that correct? True. True, all of it true.
All of it true. That's sort of, I fell off the stage and I just looked at my ankle and broke my leg. And then I felt no pain. So I was like, I'm gonna go fix this, I'll be right back. And I looked at the band and was like, just play a queen song, just go, go, go, go.
And they pulled me off to the side of the stage and the guy, it was in Sweden, he takes off my high top. And he's like, your ankle's dislocated, I must put it back in right now. And so I'm like, oh my God. So I got this huge cup of Crown Royal, I was just like bleh.
And then he puts it back in and he's holding it there. And I'm like, okay, so can I go sit down and finish the show? And he's like, why do we have to put the cast on it? And I was like, where's, okay, do you have one? He's like, no, we gotta go to the hospital. I said, how far away is that? He's like, half an hour.
I'm like, fuck that. You go get the cast and I'll go sit down. And he goes, well, if I let go of your ankle, it's just gonna fall out. And then I was like, well, then you're coming on stage, motherfucker. And this guy was like, okay. And they put this ace bandage around it.
And he came out with you? And held my foot. It was like, now again, I'm making decisions. And so he sat there and held it. As we played, it was a stadium. And we kept playing. Still no pain? No pain.
And then the throne and then you had a chair developed to continue the tour. Later gave that throne to Axel Rose. True or false? True, Axel had to use it. Oh, you wanna know what's crazy? Okay, so then Axel used it for guns and roses because he broke his foot.
And then he was also singing with ACDC at the time. So then it goes on tour with ACDC for a little bit. And then I'm the guy that people call like, hey, I broke my fucking ankle, can I borrow the throne? I was like, yeah, okay. So I started sending it out to different people. But recently, like about a month ago, there was this dude in a metal band
who stopped an active shooter at his show, at his own show. He saw this guy that was acting sketchy. And so he confronted him and the guy shot this dude in the band in the leg. And then they found his car was full of ammunition, blah, blah, blah. What? And so he and his friends started this online campaign
like, Dave, you should give him the throne. And I gave him the throne for him to play in his metal band, which was pretty reckless. So listen, if any of you guys ever need a throne, I know you've got your Spidey chair, Will, but this thing has like lasers and a smoke machine on it. That would be, that's pretty rad. That's pretty rad.
Dave, I imagine you got some real quality house time with the wife and the girls during COVID. But now, are you back on tour? Are you back on the road? Are you thinking about it? We are, we're doing some shows here and there. We're playing, well, we've been out. We went out for the last like two and a half, three months
and played all through the Midwest and did Lollapalooza and reopened Madison Square Garden. Oh, that's right. That's right. We've got some more shows coming up. And then we'll like quiet down for a little bit and then do it all again. Sean, what, isn't there like a vocal exercise
or like a sentence, not like quick Brown Fox? What is the thing you say before you do a performance? I'll do it. Yeah, let's hear it, Sean. I'll do a, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, you're welcome.
Wow. You can do that. Before a show. Yeah, go ahead. What do you do? Three Advil, two Coors Lights and two shots of drum roll. There it is. Is that true?
26 years, 26 years, right there. Is that true? It's absolutely true. You don't smoke butts though, right? You don't smoke butts. In a pinch. I do. You do.
I do. I do all the things I'm not supposed to do. You're a rock star, God damn it. It's not even that. I'm just a fuck up and I'm too lazy to do the thing Sean did before a show. You're not a fuck up. And terrified someone will hear me doing that.
But here is the deal and I don't want to embarrass you. You have been an incredibly relevant figure in rock and roll for a long, long time. You've made all these records. You have a family. You are getting up early. You're going to bed early. You're still doing all the rock star things,
but you're managing to juggle the other side as well. My hat is off to you, my friend. You definitely won. Jason is really impressed with how early you get up. Because he's just like, that's the mark of somebody who's serious. Well, you can't fake that. Shut the fuck up. We're not going to fit in your fucking box, Bateman.
OK? Of what you've drawn up, what you think should be. Because you don't even do it yourself. Shut the fuck up. I've had enough of it. Dave, Dave, you and I are rock stars, man. And we're doing it differently than everybody else. Said from a Spidey chair.
It doesn't matter. You're a fucking rad dude. And come on over to the house. We're going to lift. And I'm going to get you into sports. Sean's going to tap dance with you. And he's going to get you into promises and promise. And Bateman, you can go and eff yourself.
And that's our show. And with that, sweet, sweet Dave Grohl, thank you for joining us. I'll see you at Trader Vic. So cool to meet you, Dave. You're a treasure. What a pleasure to meet you. Thanks, fellas.
We'll see you around. OK. See you, man. Bye. Bye, buddy. That Dave Grohl. Jason, what a great guest. Look, I fanned out about the Nirvana thing
because I grew up listening to him. So I tried very hard not to ask any Nirvana questions. He doesn't want to talk about Nirvana. Why not, though? Well, because that's all he's ever talked about. Everybody always wants to ask about Nirvana. It's like this guy, I don't know. Because it's one of the most iconic bands of all time.
That's not fair. He's done 14,000 albums with the Foo Fighters. That's like somebody saying, you can't ask you. And that was our question or an arrest development question. Well, but did we hammer Paul McCartney about the Beatles? No? We should have. We should.
We should have. We did. We talked a little bit about him being from Liverpool. And we bring up Teen Wolf 2 all the time with you. We can't not talk about that. I do enjoy talking about that. Because you, as you point out, it's Teen Wolf also. Yeah, it teed up a little.
Yeah, it was not a sequel. It was not a sequel. He's great. Super guy, super funny. And he's got a brand new book out. I should have asked him. It's called The Storyteller. Is it called The Storyteller?
It's called The Storyteller. It's your favorite term, Will. It's tough. I'm going to have to. It's tough. But I do love Dave. And by the way, if you're actually writing a book and you called The Storyteller, that's OK.
So do you guys get the same sort of vibe from him that you do from me? Because we share the same exact day. I mean, do you believe in all that? Like astrology and people born on the same day are kind of the same people? Do you think Rockstar, when you look at me, when you talk to me?
First of all, I don't think that's true. I think that if you were born at the same minute, maybe, at the same place. I didn't really go that micro with it. Well, why wouldn't you? I like when he said, the parts of the band, he associated us with a clock, where like the big gear moves a little slower,
the little one moves faster, and they all come together. Will, how would you describe us three as the internal parts of a clock? First of all, I didn't know that we were going around doing like, I like when he said, oh, OK. And I like when he said, oh, no, I just remembered it. I remembered it. I like that analogy, too.
I thought that was really, really cool. Would you call me the big cock? No, there's an L, clock. Clock? Big cock, big cock. A cock, yeah. But you were very, you were real slurry on that. I was trying to slur the G just to get a joke.
I remember the big cock. I like the analogy of, I like the analogy if we were all board games. I would say, I would say Jason's chess. Will, you're checkers, and I'm probably shooting like this. Sorry. You think so? Oh, I thought you were going to say sorry.
Or I'm sorry, yeah. Well, why am I checkers? Yeah, because I'm chess. Yeah, because you're right in that. He's just calling it like he sees it, Will, you know? What are you talking about? Are you talk to Bateman? Because you travel a lot.
You can travel with checkers a little bit easier. Oh, yeah, you guys have traveled. I want to talk about that, by the way. We've never taken a trip. We're going to. Just the two of us. No, just the two of us. You, me, Sean, or you, me, Will.
We're going to do a threesome coming up in February. Get your tickies. Get your tickies. And I mentioned the merch because I did. I have, we each got one of those smart-less hoodies. When we first were coming up with it and the people who made them sent it to us. You're not going to wear that, are you?
You can't wear your own stuff. Well, this is what I'm getting to. So they sent it to the three of us to say like, hey, what do you think, right? And we all got one. And before they went on sale on the website. And so I still have mine. And it's hanging in the closet the other day.
I had it on. And sometimes they're wearing it around the house because it's actually very nice. And this is not me trying to say, they're really comfy. You should get it. Super comfy. They just put it on. And I said to the kids, I was like,
I can't wear this outside of the house ever. Cause I'm like, hey, look, Hey, there's the guy wearing his own face. Yeah. And did Archie and Abel say, you can't wear it here either. Get it off. No, they didn't.
But let me ask you something, Jason. You must have Ozark swag. Do you wear it and do you wear it outside of the house? I give a lot of it away. I've got two hats that I still, I keep in my closet for some weird reason. Like I'm going to wear them one day, which I can't. I can't go out with it.
You're one of the, Jason, are you one of those like you wear like a panavision hat? Like, Hey, just ask me if I'm a director. Yeah. A stunts unlimited hat. Just thank them for something to ask. Go ahead. Just please ask me.
What kind of mat do you use? Yeah. Something like that. Well, that's how I felt about the set, bringing, we've talked about the segues before. Remember, Jason remembers Sean, when I was on Arrested Development, which was a show Jason and I were on,
which again, you got to see. The comedy. Yeah. You should see it. Cause you like comedy. And I use, my character used to ride one of those segues, those, you know, personal people, single, whatever, people movers.
The segues. Something like that. Something like that. And I drove that thing around. It's really fun to, they were fun to ride. I could never ride it from that moment on. Cause it'd be like, Hey, Hey guy, are you riding your proper around?
It's not funny. You know, you're going to think I'm a nerd, but like I actually did like sweater vest before my character, Jack McFarland. Now I can never wear a sweater vest. Yeah. You can never wear it. Nope. Yeah. And now Jason can never wear khakis
with a sleaze rolled up on a shirt. Oh wait. He does it all the time. That's our show. Bye. Bye. Really? Oh yeah. Sorry.
Wait, was that a real buy or no? No, I don't think it can. By the way, I took a little heat the other day we were talking, I was talking to some friends and they're like, they're like, Hey, are you serious with the buys at the end of every episode? What do you mean?
Are you serious? Like they're, they're like saying, because remember the only reason we're doing it is because it's the most obnoxious, annoying thing. It's a joke. But I think we're past the joke now. And now it's just awful. What do you think?
Wait, wait, who? By the way, it goes, it depends on who said it. Who asked that? Somebody who's not prone to cynicism at all. It's actually somebody I was working with like a sound crew, like engineers at a post production session. When you were doing, you were doing a session for Hyundai?
No, a different, you know, which by the way, it's a fantastic car. Oh God. If you like safety and if you like economy and handsome lines. Anyway, so should we, should we change that at all? No. Well, we've run out of all the pun.
How about like a see ya? Why don't we move on to see ya? Yeah. Hang on, hang on, hang on. I'm not taking fucking notes from people. I don't give a shit what they think. I hate when people go, you know, so I'll tell you this, this is my last point.
And then you guys, I was in Toronto and I was with our friend Shani this week from Toronto. Friend and Shani had Tracy. At the, friend and Shani had from the Leafs game for Tracy. Who's the president of the Leafs. Love him. And he calls. Nice home opener win.
Did you go to the home opener? I was at the home opener with my dad. Sure you were. Yep, nice big win. And I was with my dad and a couple buddies and was there with Shani. We had a nice little dinner before and then we were at the thing.
Pushing through. Pushing through. And so anyway, so we were watching the thing and I said, you know that Shani often after one of our podcasts, you know, episodes comes out, he'll call me or text me and he'll be like, that was pretty good. You know what, I thought when Bateman said that was good
and I liked when Shani, he'll do it like every week. We'll talk on the phone, he'll have notes. So I realized we're watching the end of the Leafs game and his brother was there and a couple other people I go, you know, I turned to Shani and I go, you know what, man? I go, you call me after the podcast and you give me notes on the show.
So guess what, after tonight's game, I got some notes, dude. The third line needs some work. I got some notes. And did you give them? Yeah, I sure did. Did he take them? Has he implemented them yet? Well, it's all about puck possession, right?
And I think Sean, you'd agree. Yeah, I know, puck possession for sure. You could just jockey for a better puck position. And forecheck. Possession. Possession, that's what I said. Oh, you did, sorry, I've just heard. Hey, Sean, serious question.
If you were to spell forecheck, would you spell it F-O-U-R or F-O-R-E? First of all, I don't know what that is. That's why I'm asking you. On a gentleman from Prague and he's not cut, he's got a forecheck. Is that what you were saying? Now I got to say bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. What. Smart. What. Smart.
What. Smart. What. Smart. What. What. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett
Barbeco. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.